uh much like they're having problems
sorting the mail they're not going to
sort this one out uh very easily at
least not in the next few days this is a
rare saturday session
to vote on a 25 billion dollar rescue
plan for the postal service but more
interestingly michelle it would stop the
postal service at least temporarily
from removing mailboxes as we've seen in
some parts of the country
from moving around those sorting
machines and distribution centers
this is exactly everything president
trump says he doesn't want to see happen
that his postmaster general doesn't want
to see happen so while they may pass it
today in the house
it won't pass in the republican-led
senate and look all of this just
exposes a decade-long issue at the
postal service it's losing money
as it starts delivering different kinds
of things through the mail
more packages than first class mail and
you know less mail
more often so you know you lay that
against the pandemic in the upcoming
election and there's obviously a lot of
controversy and concern
but this has been a long simmering
problem that congress and the white
house have been putting off for years
and there was polling going into the
democratic national convention that
people wanted to hear
more from biden and harris about what
they would be doing with their
administration
less about president trump how did they
do it reaching those expectations
yeah it depends on who you asked you
know
biden himself uh you know didn't share
very specific details in his remarks
about what he would do but he did
outline broadly
that he would do things like a national
mass mandate
make better use of the defense
production act in his view to force the
production of medical supplies and
equipment here in the united states so
that the country is no longer dependent
on china or other countries around the
world for ppe and issues like that
talk broadly about taxes and preserving
social security but beyond that
over the course of the week very little
specific mention of what exactly
democrats would do not only if they take
back the white house
but if they take full control of
congress so we'll see in the coming
weeks
if that has any effect on the standings
not only for biden but for congressional
candidates across the country
they're enjoying the lead right now
partly because joe biden simply isn't
president trump
that may be good enough for democrats
we'll see with about 73 days to go
okay so same question now for the rnc
then ed is is the focus going to be more
on what they believe
the president believes can happen over
the next four years or more on
joe biden it's you know uh
it's a good question we we actually
don't know very much about what exactly
will go on next week the republicans are
still
scrambling to put together what was
supposed to be an in-person event in
jacksonville florida remember
uh that now will be held very similar to
the democrats from multiple cities
including the south lawn of the white
house where the president will accept
the nomination again
thursday night president has struggled
over the last several months to explain
what exactly he wants to do
should he be re-elected and much of the
focus instead has been on
biden and what he calls the radical left
and how they're overtaking the
democratic party so
over four nights we are expected to see
a lot of that and we will be listening
for sure to see if there's anything
specific the president says
about what he'd like to do should he win
another term and obviously
this is a virtual convention which is
what the republicans will also have
starting on monday how has that
connection been
with voters not having it in person
you know this is a really interesting
moment i think not only in politics but
in how we consume
television or video i mean look ratings
were down overall
on television but the streaming audience
online
was up and you talked to democrats
across the country as i did in recent
days they said
look given what we were handed the
situation we were given
uh we did a pretty good job they think
and even television critics were saying
that this was really compelling
television uh that they enjoyed it two
things i think will be repeated
that virtual roll call where they went
from every state and territory across
the country to tally up the delegates
and each state did it a little
differently and then they held a very
interesting
almost like real housewives style
reunion show of
all of the candidates who lost to joe
biden
that is something i think they should
require of all the vanquished opponents
every four years yeah i'm a watcher of
that show and yes that's exactly what it
was plus
calamari in rhode island is what we all
now know ed thank you we appreciate the
insight